yesterday new york post hillary clinton
democrats are preparing her to run i
don't know if you saw that article did
you see that yeah i'm curious to know
good pull it up let's let's read it
and uh uh did you see this or no adam i
have not adam okay go
there you go press control plus to make
it a little bigger hillary clinton
versus donald trump 2024 yep life has
become a horror movie yeah
good great title
all right so we are officially a horror
movie where the monsters never dies the
virus never ends and the next election
sees hillary clinton says donald trump
yes the two most polarizing presidential
nominees of the modern time refuse to go
away clinton and trump are more likely
than they realize namely they each live
in a reality of their own making trump
continues to insist that tony tony
election was stolen hillary but he said
she won in 2016.
what i was doing was working she told
new york magazine 2017 of bernie sanders
donald trump said i beat both of them
back then i called hillary norma desmond
of american politics ever ready for her
close-up while knuckling her grip on a
scene
that uh long ago rejected her as she
refused to rule out 2020 party leaders
were vocal about moving on job and i
never thought she was a great candidate
chuck schumer when you lose to someone
who has 40 popularity you don't blame
other things you blame yourself wow so
so so this is this is pretty interest do
you think this is a real story or do you
think this is just kind of like new york
post wanted to write a story so people
will talk about but she's not going to
be running you know i wouldn't put it
past her she's so tone deaf that it
wouldn't surprise me not only would it
not surprise me if she ran again but it
wouldn't surprise me if she ran again
and did the exact same stuff she did you
know multiple other times skipped states
just you know was totally you know
not paying attention to the actual
issues that people care about that would
be a great movie the problem is like
we're in pretty distressed times right
now like i mean look i i the person i
think should run for rep i want to see
ron desantis up there i really do
um
i think he's done an amazing job and i
think he takes no garbage and he holds
media accountable but he also like knows
when to get out of his own way the
problem with trump and you know i took
plenty of heat for criticizing trump and
it wasn't policy that i was criticizing
chris wallace chris wallace you made a
comment about how he was complaining
about chris i was tired of all of i was
just he couldn't get out of his own way
often times you called him a third
grader yeah because you know the name
calling and all of that stuff it was
just you know it's funny sometimes and
you know it revs up the base and if
you're going to a rally it can be like
oh ha ha trump made a joke but
you know the the bottom line was if he
would have just stepped back and let his
record speak for itself and just know
when to just pivot away it's not about
you it's not about a petty battle on
twitter that kind of drove me nuts after
a while so my issue wasn't with policy
on him it was with character and just
like come on man just step away and let
let these these successes be successes
so desantis you know i like governors in
these positions because they've actually
run something
and i really like him i've seen many
interviews where he's just like that's
not what's happening you know these are
the facts this is what we're doing in
florida this is the model for a free
nation and a free society
so um that's what i'm a fan of and
listen i always welcome a hillary
clinton run it's a guaranteed disaster
guarantee is a disaster you're saying no
chance she runs wait did you just say no
chance she was tone deaf as she is
really to to remix it running back
do you think that you think the
democratic party wants her back no you
think there's you know fervor for her
joe biden
clearly the democrats need to figure out
who's in their stable clearly we talked
about
michelle obama potentially being a
candidate
i've i've never thought that she was
going to run ever now i'm like well you
know if there's ever a time control over
i don't i think she runs she could win i
don't think again same thing i don't
think she wants to give up that life
would you vote for trump in 2024
against two yeah
yeah or anyone anyone anyone whoever the
democrats throw up there
this champion never i will never
vote for a big government democrat ever
i will never vote for a big government
so
my problem with trump is you know i have
to listen to what trump says and trump
we already know what he's going to say
so yeah and now he's on the vaccines odd
comments and this that i think what i
will say is today and i can't tell you
what i'm going to do next round i know i
often do a lot of write-ins because i'm
like oh these people all are just
terrible but i can't tell you what i'm
going to do today because i don't know
in that situation but my my guy is
desantis okay
his wife has health issues that he's
dealing with right now and he's
attending to right now so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]